welcome to this video this is some
episode 2 of the modern classic series
well i'll be presenting memorable games
of the last let's say roughly 25 years
so i'm looking at rather modern looking
games that still are very much worth
watching and the second episode will
feature game by current world champion
viswanathan or vishy anand played
against them top mod mod elven Mordovia
not quite sure from moldova um Victor
bulaga yet the top layer of that country
I'm played in 2003 in the Dortmund GM
tournament 2003 not so long ago and in
fact this game also has won multiple
prizes also at one best game of the
decade in info the chess informant
contests them a couple of years ago so
I'm very very well-known game but still
it needs to be in them if you look at
best games of let's say 25 years the
last 25 years um one thing that needs to
be mentioned is that this tournament in
2003 em was the best tournament that
Victor bollagan ever played he won the
Dortmund super tournament he was
actually on paper really an outsider but
he simply won this tournament and he
also be done and in the first lack that
does this was am I think six player
double double round-robin and in the
first part of the tournament aren't lost
against Mulligan one very nice game I'm
not quite sure what it was maybe it was
the caro-kann even yeah he won I roughly
remember the game he won a very nice
game against on
and yeah of course unwanted 22 yeah to
take revenge he's a very happy very
friendly a more peaceful character with
the revenge is very human you want to
get a winnin if you lost the first game
so let's see what happened money for
this aren't usually place of course he
branched out a little bit in the last
couple of years but II Horace and was
back then is may move so we gotta
caricom Oregon this flexible player
plays all kinds of openings would like
but the caro-kann here and Arnold place
the classical line Knight c3 taken and
doubled our place 97 this is a line that
he played back then Bishop f5 has some
more common maybe even back then I think
it was more coming but 97 is of course
perfectly all right the favored move by
owned by Karpov so nigh g5 the the main
idea nowadays Knight f6 was played I
explain a little bit of this this stuff
in the second episode of my episode my
openings uncovered series just uploaded
a couple of days ago they explain a bit
about White's alternatives if you want
to learn more about the caro-kann check
this out so Knight f6 you should be 3e
69 f3 should be six this is the main
line even nowadays h6 takes takes Queens
yourself now this is still play down
even today castles b6 squeegee form yeah
I now we get them to a critical point
really early in the game and here but
like some main move is actually the
somewhat strange looking king of a
this son has been played numerous times
by am cup of mostly and just a second I
wanted to check this this is art of
yakking fa de semaine move but g5 was an
interesting alternative I say was
because this game actually was a yeah
the last I prefer game where it was
played okay so King evading a bit
strange as mentioned because you lose
the right to Castle but black will get
some some tempe on the Queen when some
time and they will get in Bishop d7 and
c5 and sometimes black really can play
g16 g17 do a castle by handicap of plate
this a number of times but in the game
as well as said beloved g5 which was
very topical back then and was thought
to give black interesting play to yet to
simply get a little bit more active a
little more active game and the problem
is for widest the Queen if white would
make some nothing move now let's say you
would play out rather we had moonlit s
III just basically nothing moved he
needs to reckon with this idea I mean in
this position in fact you can play and
yeah it's a it's tricky but um like if I
can take here here here and I don't
think that white wants this so this is
the basic idea that likes black is
attacking the Queen and you don't have
so many squares but a lot of question
player c3 and sensitive three is really
stupid he played Queen h3 which is much
better this um retreats the Queen and
actually now simply threatens to take on
g5 so black needs to react to this and
he played look to g8 and this was a
known position before before this game
it has been played before and the first
thing you
you're asking yourself what is happening
if if white actually takes the pond um
you can look about at this let's say why
would take but then it gets it's funny
you should have eight taking the Queen
you don't have so many squares you go
here there's a simple G for winning a
piece and if you go here that's not f
six and it's just the same need to go
back g form now and whiter what will
lose yeah he will lose a piece at least
now you don't have this kind of this
kind of trick because at the end you
check me you get mated so he cannot take
H sticks so what what did I don't play
played rookie one which was a novelty 92
was the move that have been tried before
obviously this's I'm 92 is much more
passive but rookie one is some it's the
new move and okay it's clear white wants
to put the rocker opposite the king and
still in the middle on the eight but
then of course it's very tactical right
now so time for calculation what should
black play on let's check the obvious
move first and this is of course g4 fork
forking the Queen enter the night then
white can simply take on h6 like tech
for night and then the point Rupert xe6
so
cake c6 check let's check first what
happens if black saves the attack Rock
King f8 this is some in comparison
relatively easy should 56 check rook g7
only move and now the nice move Bishop
to g6 yeah this threatens to checkmates
using the the pin drop and yeah what
should like doing needs to play this
move it simply the only one everything
out some just the lowest made or is it
any better Queen f6 King g8 now takes on
GSN yeah it looks completely winning but
it's not that easy Queen g7 Queen d6 and
now black has the fun move Bishop f5
utilizing if this this main thread if it
wasn't for this move from this was
computed be complete nonsense why does
winning you also but it's it's not the
position that you would resign on
something hanging and we still have this
motif Queen here Queen g6 and c3 and
white has some yeah five pawns for the
p.m. it should be a rather clear
advantage but it's not entirely clear
black can can can continue here may be
alright complicated line I mean it must
be horrible to calculate this over the
board okay queenie six but what about
Bishop e7 if black simply m interposes
what what's happening then yeah why
takes Knight to f8
this is g6 check King b7 if you go to d8
there's the smooth and it's very very
strong threatening Queen takes f8 using
the pin yeah black gum like it's lost um
completely soaking here and then you
have check on f5 King yet and now the
very strong move Bishop to h6 and this
is really a difficult to foresee
probably the best defense is queen to d6
if black would take f5 you have the very
strong move rookie one and like us again
completely busted what should you do
you're threatening Queen takes f8 using
this pin black of course has move the
King already you cannot cancel or
anything so um they have what what what
should you do you can you can go here
but then you have this simple procedure
and white wins the Queen with an ongoing
attack it's completely dead you yeah you
can also like you can you can pick up
all the other pieces also now itit's to
totally lost so Bishop h6 is tricky 26
is the only move that doesn't lose
easily out right and then white could
play here Bishop f8 you should have a
tricky one check
King d8 Queen f7 with this thread you
should be seven and a position like this
in which white should have a quite clear
advantage still it's um not resign de
belen something but wider should have a
rather clear Geum so very complicated
lines with them okay we are already a
twelve moves deep from the get-go and
this was G form yeah and then at the end
below gone simply m didn't want to have
this sacrifice only six and he played
Bishop to f8 yeah this covers h6o this G
for Queen f6 it's not um not possible
anymore here I'm on played them I think
a very yeah aesthetic move I really like
it this maneuver that is playing now and
this is Queen to f5 very unusual-looking
move the a day idea is to simply get out
of this the threat of course and also to
prepare each form in fact instead of
Queen f5 here White has a very
interesting alternative and this was the
violin Ruth rook takes c6 which you of
course a calculator it's probably the
first idea that comes to your mind
simply because they take the the take on
e6 is just winning for white you get the
rook back with two points up end and
deadly attacks on this is really easy
the issue is after rook takes c6 yeah
the black doesn't need to take of course
you can go here and then you're in
really am a really strange position with
the rope hanging now and g4 threatened
and in fact black has ideas like Knight
to e5 on night to c5 immediately using
the bush upon c8 so this is really
bizarre position which is completely
unclear really cannot really tell easily
and what's going on an interesting idea
for white is simply to take on on each
6cm taking the pawn and this some leads
to as mentioned rather unclear positions
let's say something like gum Knight f6
cm and it's kept completely confusing
but what you see immediately the Queen
doesn't have fun any any any good
squares you need to go here oops this
one of course g-form queen age form yeah
now you're totally confused probably and
it's very hard to evaluate this over the
board you should be m4 for example and
if white would take now on f6 then of
course 27 there's not much else Quincy
6g takes a three and now black has some
very strong counter threats I
possibility could beam Bishop h6 root G
to King edge one need to do this
otherwise Queenie to made bishop b7
queen bee five yeah and it's a total
mess I mean very hard to tell what's
what's going on there maybe I'm from
yeah maybe why does still am should be
preferred you've got the somewhat safer
King maybe it's not a very safe king but
imagine the bishop coming here this is
some this is something to protect you
it's not so easy for black to go to g2
with the Queen yeah very tricky position
so white probably could have taken only
six
but it's not an immediate win so let's
go back and unplayed as mentioned the
various setting move Queen f5 I really
like that Queen f5 and yet this also has
the idea to invade GM poor Logan played
Bishop g7 which is some I think I'm
quite quite sensible looking move and
now each form using the h-bond to attack
the some disadvantages I think it's
really a genius idea to play Queen h3
rookie one then Queen f5 and then each
form to attack this this weakness yeah
he played the king of aid that some it's
really difficult to suggest something
else you really must attack the Queen to
to get to get any further and now quite
simply retreated so you pled Queen to f5
then H form and then back yeah I really
love this maneuver it's not the it's not
the main feature of the game but I like
it it just looks a very um yeah very
nice ok I am by the way by the way if
white would take now you must look at
this of course then black has some this
tricky response using the pin and they'd
say it's not clear at all but it's not
they're not winning for white it's
simply better what what island play TM
this this some rich ricci to h3 and
black black really puts up a good
defense it's not like you played badly
he just went into a variation which is
now known to be bad but he really defend
it very good very well rook h8 now and
now after taking um will move from the
Queen Queen g-form yeah of course the g5
pawn
is close to being lost but a black can
go for some counter play he played c5
the basic ideas to go Bishop d7 and
maybe trying to get rid of this night to
have counter play on h2 with the Queen
so that you actually can do something
with your look like it's drying for
activity here but are not simply
captured on g5 now yeah okay it develops
a piece and takes off the spawn this is
easy yeah black now captured on deform
and here I'm unemployed am a very strong
move it's not um not forced or anything
there are other interesting autologous
but I think this is really a very very
deep move anti played book a 2d one they
have been they have been there were a
ton ship see I could still consider to
take on e6 you had to calculate this
basically every move really am really AM
difficult to do but black has the
defense again you can play em yeah just
just 95 and this seems to UM seems to
hold the position it's still very
dangerous for black but this kind of
stuff doesn't seem to win outright for
white yeah of course this game it's
similar to the episode one game that I
did with the one should use the prof you
can really set up a border with the
pieces and trying to figure out all
these complications or let yourself have
a bit with with an engine on the
computer it's very nice to try to
analyze all the complications without
the machine at some it's very rewarding
interesting tactics all around rookie
six and wasn't winning outright and so
on and play group play drug 81 this
looks like
quite harmless he ran like a harmless
move from just centralizing the rook but
this rook plays a key role in what's
what's coming up next in this position
black has a hard time he's hideous worse
nope no a question but um you can still
on trying to defend your position what
he did is Bishop to d7 which has the
idea that i mentioned to try to put
pressure on a free end maybe get some
kind of counter play on h2 um in fact
this move losses by force but this is um
yeah you need to see what what's
happening it's not not at all easy to 24
see this young um he could put a better
defense with them probably move like a
five which at the moment looks like it's
not doing very much but it's certainly a
kind of waiting move try to see what
what white is coming up with the idea is
simply that you need to to have the
bishop on see aid so that you are able
to encounter those sacrifices with
responses like this on 95 this is a
problem on Bishop e7 white is still I'm
very clearly better here but it's not
losing and with such yeah violent forces
in the game another alternative worth
considering wasn't this move but it's
also not not looking looking too great
if you look at I just like this I mean
black doesn't even have an extra
material for this position that some
it's it simply it's simply bad but ok he
played Bishop d7 and ya know
played the move that you had to
calculate for ya for the whole game
basically and you really did he really
did it it took only six the rook
sacrifice so what's the point Bulaga
took the rook one simple ideas of white
if what black would take on f3 you have
this and you have a counter threat
against the rook and queen edge 2 is
just the check you go to have one you
can the clock and this and there's
simply no continuation so what's your
black do you would need to move the rock
now somewhere yep here for example and
then we move like rookie seven I
concluded on the board rookie seven what
would win the game Black has no defense
can give a check play something like
this but then there's the strong move
Queen f5 attacking them also the look
and black him like will get destroyed
him snow and simply no defense against
this attack so we cannot really take on
f3 and this leaves them yeah just the
caption now Bishop e7 check the point
checking the king and okay it needs it
needs the deck not much choice Queen g7
yeah here we take the rook so the black
king needs to go to the sixth and not
not much else yeah and now I'm the real
point of this Black's king is in the
middle of the board and you're trying to
calculate all kinds of checks and forced
variations and the beautiful thing is
white can just take on deform which wish
you did yang took on deform and this is
now completely lost for black and this
is mostly due to the fact that this rook
81 five moves ago
it's now opposed to King and black has
absolutely no defense against the attack
that's now coming over black what should
you do he played Quinn to c5 the other
possibility would be M of what you could
look at is Queen to d8 white had this
this threat on b5 this is why the Queen
moves needs to be checked so quindi ate
and then um white has the very forcing
continuation Knight takes six for
example King takes Queen g6 check and
now you're you're getting really hunt it
down something like this yeah now we've
got a funny point computer movie man
other ones how winning we should be
seven as the quickest though oops
they're not this one a green f5 is the
IDM Queenie event and shake me to come
yeah and this is actually winning the
house this King is simply simply a bit a
bit too weak so this would win it in
fact instead of knight c6 there's
another win but this is a similar to the
game also what would happen if black
would play a six you can also check this
then white would simply take the pawn as
this is a double check even yeah it's a
it's a disaster very nice so what black
plate is some he played Queen to see
five which is the toughest defense and
here actually on and missed em
a little point in what he played her
wins the game no doubt about it but yeah
he played on let's say let's check first
what he played he played them Bishop to
f5 which is not bad at all it's
Winningham but here he had them an
alternative Knight to g5 check Queen
King to c6 the only move and now they
have the really beautiful move we should
be too and this is just just absolutely
a nice this geometrical motifs what
should should like do now white is
threatening to take on the seven and he
needs to cover it and then White has
some very aesthetic finish with the move
see form covering the night and now
threatening Bishop f3 yeah woods which
is as good as a checkmate amp lucky only
has Queen to d5 two defenders and here's
Black simply has no move in move the
night it's quincy 7mate and yeah it's
such a funny piece configuration what
you can try us rook to f8 in order to to
to take the bishop but here you can go
for this line which is also very neat as
now after King c7 there's not a 60 after
king d 693 winning the Queen so um yeah
like a can still take here but after
this the squeem d6 check checkmate
threatened and still the rope hanging so
yeah what is simply winning yeah this
was a very aesthetic way to finish this
but
yeah probably didn't have so much time
left and he had calculated Bishop f500
once and okay it is winning as well so
it's just the very very minor point that
was missed here to to finish the game
quicker at them this is strong enough as
long so Queen to e5 it's the toughest
defense and hard enough in this position
to find any move that I have a player
really so Knight f3 check when you can
look at alternatives and set off Queen
the Queen to UM 25 but I think you're
you're hard-pressed to find anything
let's say should be 5 to block this then
white simply takes and this kind of
stuff you don't survive damn you simply
don't survive this why does got the
three extra points outside black needs
to to give the Queen now turn to avoid
getting mated yeah Queenie five was some
relatively the best choice to to
continue on that every check queen to d5
right now he took the Queen okay a
couple of checks and now just push it
before at the end it's two extra pawns
and still the very bad King position
which is a pretty pretty easy win and it
didn't last much longer that rook age
five
night each form directly going for this
dangerous check rook gah so check into
d8 Queen f7 yeah and now we see that
it's all too much it simply wasn't
defensible anymore when true p 8 and now
the silver move should be three get
below gone resigned it's too it's two
pawns and it's simply simply too much or
it has multiple ideas Bishop b5 or
simply push the pawns well not be p2 to
be five but let's say before first he
can numb as multiple ways to improve its
position and legs pieces are simply are
simply not working together it said it's
a complete one so only a very minor spot
on this on this beautiful game what I
enjoy about this game is this very
static maneuver Queen f5 each form and
then back this really am was the key to
get this this pawn oops notice this pawn
configuration weekend on g5 and h6
and of course it was was brilliant this
rook 81 move after which black really
doesn't have a movie whatever it tries
is in YouTube's trouble and the direct
point and this continuation here is just
great that you'd use the default ooh and
down the king yeah really a great game
yeah are not displayed them a ton of
brilliant detecting games you could
easily do um do a yeah weekly show on
that and it would feel good soft I'm if
you if you would want to alright i hope
you enjoyed this game and cal I'll
continue the series on and off simply um
yeah not on a weekly basis maybe but um
quite often that joined lot to to look
at those beautiful games again and very
often I'll ask them looked at them
really years ago when they were played
and enjoyed a lot to to sort of yeah
recap we kept those those nice effort
some here okay yeah thanks for watching
and I'll be back soon with new content